on vit à défaut d'avoir strictement
atteint la parité hommes femmes en
matière politique on se réjouira de la
stricte parité euro dollar au chapitre
économique ainsi aujourd'hui un euro
valait exactement un dollar la monnaie
européenne s'apprécie ce qui fait les
affaires de ceux qui voyagent aux états
unis notamment en revanche pour les
entreprises qui exportent ce n'est pas
une bonne nouvelle explication amaury
guibert et alain poiré
dans cette agence de voyages il se passe
quelque chose d'étonnant avec les etats
unis une destination délaissé depuis le
11 septembre et pourtant on peut
constater que la demande est beaucoup
plus importante que l'offre et
aujourd'hui il est difficile d'avoir un
billet pour les états unis et si les
placements s'est il est devenu moins
cher de voyager outre atlantique grâce à
l'euro il n'avait cessé de baisser
depuis sa création puis il s'est
redressé par rapport au dollar
aujourd'hui les deux monnaies sont à
parité entre temps l'économie américaine
a beaucoup souffert conséquence lui en
septembre scandales financiers à
répétition
les investisseurs ont déserté le dollar
ils ont acheté de l'euro et l'euro est
remonté un euro fort ça des avantages le
pétrole facturées en dollars est moins
cher et le prix du litre à la composent
cela dit il ne faudrait pas que l'euro
s'emballe
attention aujourd'hui un euro trop fort
serait un danger pour notre croissance
est connue parce que sinon ça limiterait
nos exportations notamment celles de
l'allemagne et en allemagne le seul
moteur ce sont les exportations si
jamais vous avez un euro qui est trop
fort risque de casse également la
croissance chez lui car le succès de
l'euro ne veut pas dire que tout va bien
en europe au contraire la croissance est
toujours fragile en fait les marchés
trop juste que cela va encore moins bien
aux états unis pour le moment